in this video we're going to understand
how to manage a model repository on the
hugging face model hub
in order to handle a repository you
should first have a hugging face account
a link to create a new account is
available in the description
once you are logged in you can create a
new repository by clicking on the new
model option
you should be facing a similar model to
the following
in the owner input you can put either
your own namespace or any of your
organization's namespaces
the model name is the model identifier
that will then be used to identify your
model on the chosen namespace
the final choice is between public and
private
public models are accessible by anyone
this is the recommended free option as
this makes your model easily accessible
and shareable the owners of your
namespace are the only ones who can
update and change your model
a more advanced option is the private
option
in this case only the owners of your
namespace will have visibility over your
model
other users won't know it exists and
will not be able to use it
let's create a dummy model to play with
once your model is created comes the
management of that model
three tabs are available to you you're
facing the first one which is the model
card page
this is the page used to showcase your
model to the world we'll see how it can
be completed in a bit
the second one is the files and versions
tab
your model itself is a git repository
if you're unaware of what is a git
repository you can think of it as a
folder containing files
if you have never used git before we
recommend looking at an introduction
like the one provided in this video's
description
the git repository allows you to see the
changes happening over time in this
folder hence the term versions
we'll see how to add files and versions
in a bit
the final tab is the settings tab which
allows you to manage your model's
visibility and availability
let's first start by adding files to the
repository
files can be added through the web
interface thanks to the add file button
the added files can be of any type
python json text you name it
alongside your added file and its
content you should name your change or
comment
generally adding files is simpler by
using the hugging face hub python
library or by using the command line
we'll showcase how to do this using the
hugging facehub python library and there
is a link in the description to the
previous version of this video
showcasing how to do this using git in
the command line
first make sure you're logged into your
hugging face account either through the
command line or in a python runtime
the first approach we'll take a look at
is using the upload file method
this offers an extremely simple api to
upload files to the hub
the three required parameters are the
current location of the file
the path of that file in the repository
and the id of the repository to issue
pushing
there are a few additional parameters
the token parameter if you would like to
specify a different token than the one
saved in your cache with your login
the repo type parameter if you would
like to push to a data set
or a space
will upload a file called readme.md to
the repository using this method
we first start by saving a file with
that name which contains some
information about the repository itself
here a title
now that the file is saved let's use the
upload file method to upload it to the
hub
if we switch to the web interface for a
second and refresh the page we'll see
that the readme is shown
the file upload was a success
alongside this method exists a delete
file method so that you may manage your
repository fully
we'll use it to delete the file we have
just created
if we refresh the page once again good
the file was indeed deleted
this approach using only these two
methods is super simple
it doesn't need git or get lfs installed
but it does come with a limitation
the maximum file size one can upload is
limited to 5 gigabytes
to overcome this limit let's take a look
at the second method which is using the
repository utility
this class is a wrapper over git and git
lfs methods which abstracts most of the
complexity and offers a flexible api to
manage your online repositories
let's take a look at how it works
we first start by instantiating the
repository utility
we provide the clone from parameter in
order to clone the repository we just
created
the repository is now cloned in the
local folder folder
the repo object that we have just
initialized offers quite a few methods
which are useful for us
we're interested in pushing a model to
the hub
i'll start by loading a model and
tokenizer i trained a few hours ago
we'll now follow the traditional git
approach by first pulling latest changes
using the gitpull method
we just cloned the repository so unless
this is a super active repository it's
unlikely that new changes are available
but it's always a good idea to pull the
latest changes before doing anything new
now that we have pulled the repository
i'll save the model and tokenizer inside
that folder this includes the model
weights configuration file and tokenizer
files
now that the model is saved we'll
continue with the traditional git
approach and push it to the remote
repository
if we were using the command line there
are a few git nfs specific commands we
would have to invoke but here the
hugging phase hub package takes care of
all of that we'll start by staging the
files using the git add method
we'll then commit these changes using
the git commit method and providing a
helpful commit message
finally we'll push the changes to the
remote using the git push method
if we go back to the files and versions
tab we can now see the newly committed
files
we can even play with the model in the
inference api
unfortunately the front page of our
model is still very empty
let's add a readme markdown file to
complete it a little bit
this readme is known as the model card
and it's arguably as important as the
model and tokenizer files in a model
repository it is the central definition
and documentation of your model ensuring
reusability by fellow community members
and reproducibility of results providing
a platform on which other members may
build their artifacts
we'll only add a title and a small
description here for simplicity's sake
but we encourage you to add information
relevant to how was the model trained
its intended use and limitations as well
as its identified potential biases
evaluation results and code samples on
how to use your model
great work contributing a model to the
model hub this model can now be used in
downstream libraries simply by
specifying your model identifier